Ukrainian forces are accelerating
their territorial advances
into Russian-held areas.
Vladimir Putin's military could be
on the verge of collapse.
Russian President Vladimir Putin now
threatening to use nuclear
weapons.
Biden said the risk of nuclear
Armageddon is at the highest level
since 1962.
President Biden has said that the
world hasn't been this close to
nuclear Armageddon since the 1962
Cuban Missile Crisis.
Vladimir Putin has issued grave
threats and then backtracked.
In late September, he announced in a
televised address that he would use
all available means to protect
Russia and our people.
"This is not a bluff", he said.
Then in a speech on October 27th,
he said, referring to nuclear
weapons, "There is no point in that,
neither political nor military."
But The New York Times reported last
week that Russian military leaders
recently held meetings without Putin
to discuss when and how to use
tactical nuclear weapons in Ukraine.
Antiwar.com's Scott Horton, editor
of the new book Hotter than the Sun
Time to Abolish Nuclear Weapons.
Says that we should take seriously
the idea that the conflict in
Ukraine could escalate to
a world-ending war.
From the very beginning of the war.
I mean, in his declaration of war,
he threatened to use nukes against
any country that intervened, namely
us. And then his defense minister
and head of its National Security
Council as former President Medvedev
is Foreign Minister Lavrov
as well. They've all threatened to
use nuclear weapons since this war
began at different times.
Biden's stated policy
is to help Ukraine no matter how
long it takes to win back their
territory.
That logically can't be accomplished
without throwing us in
extraordinarily high nuclear
risk.
Daniel Davis, a senior fellow for
defense priorities and a former
lieutenant colonel in the U.S.
Army, believes that despite recent
setbacks, the Russian army is
unlikely to back down any time soon.
I don't buy into the narrative
that the Russian army writ large is
trash, and I hear that all the time,
or that they've been humiliated.
They have made a number of
significant mistakes, but they've
also shown that they can learn from
mistakes. And some time in the
latter part of November and first
part of December, there is an
expected massive
invasion re-invasion
re-offensive coming.
I think you're going to see a
significant swing back in the
Russian side at that point.
Ukrainian President Vladimir
Zelensky said in late October that
his goal was to drive Russia out of
all parts of Ukraine, including
Crimea, which it annexed in 2014.
The Russian military would fight
to the T to keep that from
happening, but in the event that the
policy was successful, then
the chance goes way up
that Russia would use
nuclear weapons. Because I don't
think that Putin can survive
if he allowed his troops his merely
his conventional forces to be
defeated and physically driven
back into Russia and not used
nuclear weapons. I don't think the
hardliners in his country would
allow him to stay in power if he did
it. And I think he knows that what
we should be doing is, hey, let's
let's help Ukraine with
defensive weapons so that they keep
Russia from just rolled it across
them. At the same time, backdoor
negotiations and diplomatic
channels with both sides to say,
hey, y'all figure this out.
Figure out a way that we can bring
this to an end for everybody's
sake. But we should not be
pursuing something that probably
can't be accomplished.
And if it did, it would put us in
nuclear risk.
Horton says that a diplomatic
solution could have been reached
back in April, pointing to an
article co-written by Fiona Hill,
a former senior director for
European and Russian affairs on the
National Security Council, stating
that, according to multiple former
senior U.S. officials in April
2022, Russian and Ukrainian
negotiators appeared to have
tentatively agreed on the outlines
of a negotiated interim settlement.
According to a Ukrainian newspaper
and a press release from the British
government, then prime minister
Boris Johnson urged Zelensky to
avoid such negotiations with Russia.
They had a deal in principle
ready to be signed where the
Russians would end the war,
agree to pull back to where they
were on February the 23rd.
So that's like, you know, just
barely into the Donbass region in
the very early hours of the
invasion, essentially.
And and then that would be it.
They would call a truce right there.
But Ukraine would have to, you know,
I guess, enshrine it in their
constitution and give a real
guarantee that they would forswear
any future attempt to join
the NATO alliance and then
essentially force, you know,
guarantee their neutrality going
forward. And that would have been
it.
In late September, Putin announced
the annexation of four Ukrainian
territories that border Russia,
asserting that residents of the
occupied territories would be
Russian citizens forever.
The Kremlin warned that Ukrainian
attacks against any of the annexed
regions would be considered
aggression against Russia itself.
Now you're asking me.
In early October,
after Putin has made this
terrible escalation
in semantics
only, but it means everything.
He has now claimed to
have absorbed what
I don't know how many square miles.
These four huge oblast,
these provinces of Eastern Ukraine
here to get him to back down from
that. I think it's going
to be virtually impossible now.
I would tell Blinken, I would, like,
grab him by his ear like his angry
step mom.
Right. And help him get on the
plane. Go to Geneva,
tell Lavrov you're sorry
and you're willing to try to work
this out now and find a way,
dammit. Ceasefire first
and then see what we can do.
Nobody in Ukraine and nobody in
the West wants to allow Russia
to keep one inch of territory
that they've taken.
But look, I'm just going to be blunt
and just say this straight up.
We have to deal with the reality
that exists, not the picture
that we wish existed.
The picture we wish existed is
that we'll just give Ukraine enough
support and eventually they'll drag
Russia back and they'll have all
their territory and then
there'll be a full hold in
democratic country.
I mean, that's what we say and
that's what we would desire.
But we have to bank on reality,
because the truth is that the harsh
core, hard core reality
is that to try and accomplish that
objective is to almost certainly
escalate the fight to
a nuclear conflict.
So we instead have to do what is
realistically possible.
And what is realistically possible
is to freeze the war where it's at
right now before Ukraine loses
any more territory.
And while they have a chance
to make some kind of negotiation
to where they can keep the majority
of their country and then
have some kind of cessation
of war, that where they can at least
live next door to each other.
And then there's no more threat of a
war for anyone. No more refugees,
no more cities destroyed, no more
people killed, no more soldiers
lost. That's what we should be
shooting for.
Yale historian Timothy Snyder has
written that negotiating with Putin
will only make future nuclear war
much more likely because the lesson
for future dictators would be that
all they need is a nuclear weapon
and some bluster to get what they
want.
Nothing's changed because of this
conflict. I mean, that already
exists, and that's part
of the reality.
Russia has nuclear weapons.
North Korea has nuclear weapons.
You're not going to roll that back.
So we need to keep that number
small, but we also
have to concurrently deal.
And I keep saying this with the
reality.
Reality is Russia has nuclear
weapons and it can escalate.
So we have to deal where we can.
Now, let me also add in to that,
that it's a myth to suggest
that, oh, well, look, Russia all
they did is have to have nuclear
threats. And, you know, now then
they get all this stuff.
Look, Russia has so badly
harmed itself with all of the losses
that it sustained up to this point
already, that it's going to take
decades to recover from that.
A lot of these sanctions will never
be rolled back, at least not in our
lifetimes.
And so the harm that the nation
of Russia has suffered already
and will continue to suffer is
significant and hardly a
blueprint for anyone else to want to
follow.
Horton says the war in Ukraine shows
that deterrence is too risky of a
strategy and should reinvigorate the
push for disarmament.
That only works until it stops
working. And once it stops working,
then that's it.
You know, it's called the Doomsday
Machine because it's made to be used
completely.
I was on Fox News the other night
and the liberal Democrat says, oh,
come on, we have mutually assured
destruction.
In other words, they can't touch
us, so we can do whatever
we want to them in Ukraine
because there's no way they're going
to reach out and touch us here in
North America because that would be
nuclear war and they would never
dare to do such a thing.
Well, that's just not true.
That kind of thinking is the kind of
thing that'll get us killed.
That's the kind of thinking that
Russia's nuclear arsenal is supposed
to prevent.
And yet somehow it doesn't.
There's too much casual talk about,
all of a sudden, American forces
fighting in the war against Russia
on the side of Ukraine.
That is ludicrous.
There is nothing going on
in the border dispute between
Russia and Ukraine that has anything
to do with American national
security.
So the idea that we would risk our
security by involving ourselves
in this potential war that could
escalate up to a nuclear conflict is
absurd in the highest degree,
and we should not do it.
I am afraid, John, that it's going
to come down to some
absolutely horrible
incident and somehow hopefully
we get through that and people
will recognize we've got to scale
back the other way.
I'm not recommending that.
I'm just saying I don't know what
else is going to get through to
people. I'm afraid that that's what
it's going to come to.
And frankly, I don't believe that
if one atom bomb goes off,
I don't think that it can stop.
I am on the most pessimistic
person in the world as far as that
goes. I think if anybody uses an
atom bomb anywhere, America blows up
the whole world, period.
Henry Kissinger himself a
few months ago said, "Hey, hey,
we need to find an
exit ramp out of this thing now
before this gets out of control."
That should be all you need to know
about how dangerous this is.
And frankly, I wouldn't mind, he
would need a chaperon, but I
wouldn't mind involving him in
diplomacy right now.
If we sent Henry Kissinger to meet
with Sergei Lavrov in
in Geneva tomorrow, I
would celebrate that as the greatest
invention of peace in our time right
now.